[Music]
okay we just got done seeing one the
canoe Reeves flick called replicas and
it this movie just appeared out of
nowhere there were no trailers no
promotion it didn't even say coming soon
on the AMC app I just we just looked and
dance-pop they're like Keanu Reeves and
it looks like a yes go check it out so I
get into the theater and I real quick I
just kind of curious I went to go see if
there were any reviews on it and the did
the critic reviews are [ __ ] terrible
they're like one-star that tell me how
bad the movie is so movie starts
watching it [ __ ] loved it
but a good movie man there's nothing
wrong with this movie now it's not John
wick it's a you know it's not at that
level
it's not a blockbuster it's just a well
thought out well-written fun low-budget
science-fiction thriller thriller yeah
yeah no it's well shot it's got a good
story the act he's good Reeves this
reven Reeves in the [ __ ] out to the
whole thing you know you know how he is
okay but he did he did a good job you
know there's a couple scenes where
there's a robot
it's CGI it doesn't look all that good
you know by today's standards it looks
like maybe the old Will Smith movie I
Robot exactly yeah it looks like imagine
if that had a baby with Terminator 1 yes
look like it's about a guy who works at
a company called bio dine which it
sounds like a cyber die and a bio 9
9 some it's supposed to be in the future
but they don't really tell you how far
in the future yeah you can't really tell
how far I don't think it's me that they
did a good job by not by leaving that
kind of it yeah he's figured out how to
transfer human consciousness into work
into perhaps robots or and clones yeah
with this company well they're trying to
do it they're trying to well
accidentally I think into a car retinas
family gets killed so he and his buddy
grabbed the bodies of the family and
steal the Stila constant is right like a
main science Berg and they use it in an
experiment right well he does he he gets
it done but he didn't really think it
out too well he was in a bad emotional
state yeah all right so can't spoil
anything about it just I'd recommend the
movie how do you guys it's like like I
said it's one of those things where I
guess you can't really think about it
too hard about it me very much of like
of like a FEMA B from the 50s like
premise wise but it's like updated from
here okay where you just kind of have to
roll with it
yeah I don't think about it just have a
good time it you know what it reminded
me like a little bit like a more
sophisticated up-to-date version of arms
worth sniggers the fifth day I was
thinking that you yeah yeah and I love
that movie not too long ago I was like
it's kind of a similar story where yeah
you know it's kind of trying to ask the
question it's like what makes a person a
person like you like somebody like a
copy or they yes I'll be the same person
or not right they get into that I would
you know they're just I don't know why
the critics didn't like that movie
anything wrong with it yeah it's not
you know like I said it's not a big
blockbuster type of movie and did you
give that a 10 percent no no [ __ ] no
they're giving that a 1 out of 10
basically yes we're talking about
no it's almost kind of like they got
some against this movie and then they
didn't promote it that's what was really
odd it's like I didn't see cuz we've
seen like trailers for pretty much
everything that's coming out yeah and
some of it [ __ ] but we have wheat I
didn't see a trailer for this I didn't
hear anything about it I didn't like you
know I can't read this looks still a
pretty famous person so yeah I don't
know why I didn't hear anything about
it's like yeah we just we were looking
for movies to see this week and it just
popped up on that yeah this is a
perfectly enjoyable science fiction okay
it's like you know it's the format of
the movie feels very 2000s early 2000
yeah it is kind of a you know the
eighties throwbacks are becoming kinda
kind of popular this is almost kind of
like a very late 90s early 2000 throw
like Minority Report and I Robot and
yeah it's very much yeah and 5050 you
know I liked it though so if you see
yeah so if you like those type of movies
then I don't see why you wouldn't like
this one not Rama display enjoy yeah
nothing wrong this mode and you know the
car left it up left it where maybe there
could be a sequel to this that they
wanted yeah I mean you know they
finished up the story but yeah they left
it open-ended where [ __ ] happens and you
know I liked the tone of the movie there
was you weren't sure if things were
going right or not and then it kind of
had a the ending on it was quite cool
yeah I wasn't expecting that ending but
I you leave the theater feeling good so
yeah but you know it's kind of cool yeah
you
okay we just got done seeing one called
the upside but it was based on a true
story what was the name of these guys
that actually started this
do you know those guys yeah there was
Kevin Hart and Bryan Cranston okay yeah
Nicole Kim she'd Nicole Kim isn't
everything past couple she's like a lot
of movies the last damn she must have
problems or something's wrong the IRS
gotta pay out their bills or I mean
she's super famous yeah yeah been pretty
good it was he called a comedy drama
kind of like Odd Couple buddy flick it
was it was good it was it was a good
mixture of comedy and drama
I enjoy it what do you think yeah I
liked it a lot too I mean especially the
two actors that they had like at the I
mean they just had such great rapport
with one another you know to me and it's
like if you see the trailers you know
that it's like it's like I said it's
based on true story about this very very
wealthy man who was in an accident
became a quadriplegic and ends up hiring
basically next cautery yeah a man who
wasn't even applying for that job hey do
you really want that job yeah he just
kind of gave it to him kinda it seemed
like he did it for like shits and
giggles yeah other things to make his
other assistant mad or to make his other
matters like that but they end up
developing like this really close
friendship and you know and I think Dell
the character played by Kevin part is
like he like gives him a second lease on
life you know right so it's kind of it's
like you said it's a little bit like a
fish out of water kind of story too but
it's you know that's a really good bit
based on the based on the trailers I
thought it was gonna be something more
along the lines I remember the movie
Trading Places
yeah yeah if that was gonna be like that
but really what it what it came out is
really you know it's a lot more like
that movie what was it sent to a woman
remember button yeah along with the
blind guy kind of reminded me of that
movie if you like that movie you'd like
this one there's a long time yeah
theater so whatever yeah but no I
thought I thought was pretty good it was
it was excellent I thought I did we saw
it yes back and it seems like everybody
really liked it a lot of laughter yes
yeah there's good reflexes good reaction
from the crowd yeah yeah all right
okay Jenny and I just got done seeing
there's a dog moving what was the name
of it
the dogs way home dogs way homeless
about about a dog who got lost and had
to find his way back home you know just
like the title of difficult to judge a
movie like this because yeah I guess I
guess it's a kids movie the dog did I'll
tell you it this is one of the biggest
pieces of [ __ ] I've actually ever seen
that movie was [ __ ] difficult Madison
threw that thing the voice acting and
the script with really really wood and
really terrible nothing gelled there
wasn't any smooth transitions from one
thing to the next the quality of the
movie I would say be like on par with
like a really badly done hallmark really
bad CGI bad bad voice-acting
and it wasn't so much the actress who
was doing the voice acting it was the
description and what's funny is that
this it's being narrated by a dog but
none of the other animals actually st.
can talk or anything like it just didn't
really make any sense the every
character and it was some kind of
over-the-top stereotype you had just
know just it was just bad well like I
said it's um I guess it's based on the
book can't from the name of the guy that
that writes them but he's written less
[ __ ] some of these I guess he wrote like
a dog's journey that was about like dog
reincarnation and they're also making a
movie out of that because cuz of the
trailer dog reincarnation yes and it's
like honestly it's like we're kind of
there wasn't a lot of movies play it
we'll see it's either this or bye
we were at the mood for a political
movie Silvana - yes
it's like like I said it's probably fine
for kids but there was a kid in the
audience that kid didn't give a [ __ ]
about this that kid was like Nick and
I'm almost funnies there were old people
in the theater and they were chuckling
and I was like man they're entertained
by this I want I just wanted out of
there but the weird thing is that most
of the cats that were in it like other
than the wild cats at the beginning that
like saved the puppy and everything like
that hero cats they were real but their
motion was seemed like it was CGI I mean
later on yes I know you can't train
Bobcats or Cougars or anything like that
the CGI like on the Cougar was pretty
bad it was just a tiger on Walking Dead
was better Oh tiger I'm walking down a
lot it was just a the movie was you
could you can tell that the movie we
just kind of thrown together and it was
made on the fly it was made she says
those books are so successful yeah I
don't know how many of them there are
like I said I know of a dogs journey and
I know about this one I was under the
impression that there were a lot of
these and they were like a lot of
bestsellers it's just a very I think
snopes.com has a word for it they call
it the urge where it's just like this
just overly sappy kind of like trying to
manipulate your emotions yeah and it's
not really working and it's like that
and don't get me wrong like I love
animals seriously you know so I'm not
I'm not [ __ ] to us the poor the poor
dogs and cats it had to be in this movie
well they also tried to even kind of
bring it you know I'm a veteran you know
I'm a disabled vet even brought in the
VA and soldiers should end the soldier
[ __ ] was so [ __ ] cheesy in this
it really weighs even me as I was
looking barest as prior service I'm like
oh [ __ ] it's just because the way all
that all the all the veterans are
portrayed was just stereotypical
over-the-top
everything was offensive about it
everything was a [ __ ] offensive
including like all the attempts of being
PC were just offensive
it was come on and what and when the
movie started it showed thee it showed
the studio and it's English and Chinese
characters so this is some kind of a
Chinese studio of working here in the
United States I know that out of like
the six big studios five of them are now
under Chinese ownership so I think part
of what they do is churn out a bunch of
because I've seen that logo before and
they're all kind of like this hallmark
level lifetime level productions like
something you see on television on a
cheap cable channel it seems like
there's there's one of them out there
that's just making those and this is one
of rough you know but just I just feel
bad
you